The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
NEEMA NASSIR: Let's
go ahead and start.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Neema Nassir.
I'm a post-doctoral associate
at Transit Lab, MIT.
I've been invited to give a
few lectures in this course
and basically participate
in delivering the course
material for this course.
I will be talking
in this session
and in the next session on
Short-range Planning Practice.
And then I'll be back again
in April and in four sessions
in April, lecture number
13, 14, 15, and 16
dealing with vehicle scheduling,
crew scheduling, network
and root structure and
high ridership corridors.
So let's go ahead and start.
In this session, we are going to
talk about short-range planning
practice.
And basically, I will give
a brief set of definition
and concepts and
introduction to the planning
activities that are usually
made at transit authorities
in the US and also worldwide.
And then we will briefly
talk about the measures
and the standards and guidelines
that are published and used
by transit agencies to plan
their service based on those.
Then we will also talk about
current practice and critique
of the existing systems.
Probably we will cover icon
1 and some material in icon 2
this week.
And then the rest will
actually be delivered to you
in our session next Tuesday.
So the planning decisions and
the planning activities that
are usually done at the
transportation planning
agencies and public transport
planning agencies usually can
be classified into four
different type of decisions
depending on frequency of
decision-making and the need
for making decisions and
the scope of decisions--
the scope of changes that are
related to the decisions that
are made with each activity.
These planning
activities are divided
into four different classes--
long range planning activities,
medium range, short range,
and control.
Long range planning
activities basically include
major capital investment--
major improvements to
the infrastructure--
which would include construction
of a new station, a new rail
line, a new bus
way to the system.
Or it could also be
related to and as a result
of major institutional changes
and changes to the, basically,
financial resources
of the organization.
The decisions that [INAUDIBLE]
involve long range planning
are usually driven by political
and economic considerations.
And basically, the
type of analysis
and the type of planning that
is done in long range planning
activities involve projection
into the future and prediction
of demand and prediction
of situation in the future.
Therefore, it requires
a comprehensive analysis
usually for any strategic
planning of interactions
between changes in land
use and interaction
between land use and
demand in the future.
And it basically needs
to capture or have, like,
an insight into the future of
the network and of the region.
The next range is
basically or the next class
of planning activities
is basically
the medium range activities.
Medium range activities include
bus network structure design,
network size design and
improvement, fleet size,
fare policy and technology.
It basically involves
incremental or medium
improvement to the system
and to the transit service.
One point that I need to mention
about the long range and medium
range is that
these two, although
are really important
in the planning
practice for
transportation systems,
but these decisions are usually
done at the upper level--
at the higher lever than
the transit authority.
For example, long
range decisions
are usually done
in collaboration
between NPO's metropolitan
planning organizations,
state departments
of transportation,
and transit authorities.
So the transit authority is
not the final decision maker
in that case.
And it needs close interaction
and close collaboration
with the higher
level organizations
and governmental agencies
to make the final decisions.
So that's about the long range.
Medium range is also
somehow similar.
It usually, for
example, the decisions
that are related to the network
structure, although there
is a lot of interesting research
going on in universities that
deals with optimization of
network design and optimization
of the structure of the
network, because what happens
in practice is that usually
in the networks that we live
and in current cities, the
actual layout and structure
of the network is already given.
And it's usually rare
or impossible that we
start from scratch and start to
design a network from scratch
to begin with.
So therefore, what
we usually observe
is incremental changes to
the network and addition
or elimination of some routes
from the service and basically,
decisions that are
related to that.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: In terms
of fleet size,
could that come as a
request from the agencies?
Like, an agency says,
we have a bus line.
It's at capacity
or over capacity.
We need more buses.
Could it come, like, from a
request to the higher level?
NEEMA NASSIR: Yes, definitely.
Yeah, but it eventually requires
the interaction on those,
so securing the funding
from the upper level
governmental agencies--
so yeah.
So the reason that
I'm explaining this
is that I'd like for you to
understand why we are focusing
on short range decision-making
and short range planning
practice in this course.
That's mainly because the bulk
part of activities at transit
agencies is related to short
range planning and short range
decision-making.
So what we mean by short
range decision-making
are decisions that are
usually made more frequently
than a yearly basis.
And they basically
entail decisions
about the structures
of the route--
layout of the route--
layout of the stops--
and basically decisions about
the frequency of service--
timetable-- and vehicle
and crew scheduling.
Despite the top two
classes of decision-making
that are usually driven
by political and economic
considerations, short
range decision making
and control activities are
usually basically driven
by cost optimization.
And these are basically
tactical decisions as opposed
to strategic decisions that
are usually in the long range
and medium range.
So then there's real time
and control decision-making,
which is basically
usually done currently
in using expert decision
and expert activities.
There is an ongoing
effort in the technology
to improve the
quality of control--
ongoing research to
use real time data
and improve the real
time performance
by using real time control.
This includes revisions
of the routes.
That could be the
case in reaction
to incidents and
disruption situation.
It could also relate to holding
and dispatching decisions--
thank you--
that could actually
be used to improve
the effective capacity of the
system by trying to regulate--
have a better frequency,
basically, in the service.
So similar to the
typical planning problem,
there are major
elements in planning
for public transportation
and particularly
in short term and short
range decision-making.
It includes data
collection similar to what
you guys have done in your
homework assignment number 2.
Collection of data on demand,
collection of data on supply,
and interaction of
supply on demand
is an essential part to be able
to make decisions and make them
basically reliable and
actionable intelligence
for the decision-making process.
Then there should be
analysis on identification
of potential problems and
identification of opportunities
to improve the situation.
And then there is
the creative part
of design of options,
solution, and strategies
to address the situation.
And then typical to
any economic analysis,
there would be an
element of cost
and benefit estimation to be
able to justify the project.
So in terms of operational
planning process
or in another term short
range planning process,
there are multiple stages
involved in the work.
And usually, what happens
is that in practice,
it is proven that the
planning procedure
can be decomposed into
sequential decision-making
processes.
And although it is
possible to formulate
all of these decisions into one
gigantic optimization problem
and solve it for all
the decision variables
that you need to basically
address, however,
the practice has
shown that there's
a nice way of
decomposing the process
and to solve problems and solve
them sequentially in order
to make sure that
you're satisfying
all the constraints
to the accurate level
and you're gaining the--
you finally get a
realistic optimal solution
for your planning practice.
Considerations regarding
policy constraints and some
of the economic
concerns are usually
difficult to formulate
into optimization problems.
But there are
published guidelines
by governmental agencies
that you can basically
follow and make sure
that at least the top two
level of the decision-making
processes and tasks
here are basically done
to the satisfactory level.
So let's go ahead and start
and review these tasks.
There are lectures
in this course that
are dealing with each
one of these tasks
and components in planning.
But in this lecture,
I'll just briefly
go over these
different components
as an introductory
part of the course.
So for every
optimization problem
or in this case
planning process,
we have a set of inputs--
constraints-- basically,
that you need to satisfy.
And then there's an
objective function
that you need to
optimize-- so inputs.
So the first component of
the planning and practice
here is bus route design.
This includes design
of layout of the routes
and layout of the stops.
And basically, the
input into this task
includes constraints that are
related to right-of-way roadway
constraints, like if there
is a river in your network,
there's this connectivity.
There are bridges-- tunnels.
So these are the kind of
constraints at network level
that you would like to satisfy.
And there's also demand
constraints in the network
that you need to
consider for this task,
like, you have a sense of what's
the demand from certain suburb
to the downtown area.
And you basically would
like to have a route
system that kind of
can address that demand
and satisfy that demand.
Then the solution to the
design component and that task
[INAUDIBLE] out of
routes and layout
of the stops that are
basically resulting
from the first
component, and then
the set of routes
and stops will be
input into the second task,
which is setting timetables.
This task includes finding
frequencies for the routes
and from that identifying
and defining--
basically, generating
the timetables
based on frequencies.
There are usually considerations
related to policy headways,
policy frequencies, and
capacity frequencies
that need to be
addressed in this task.
But again, this task
is also somehow dealt
with using the
existing guidelines
and just satisfying
these guidelines.
The input and other
constraints that
are considered for
this task would
be level of service
guidelines, and again,
the demand constraints
in the network.
Then from the set of timetables,
what will be resulted here
is the departure times that
was scheduled for the service.
So the first two components
of row 1 and row 2,
basically, are dealing
with satisfying the demand
and satisfying the guidelines.
But once you go beyond
the first two components,
it becomes to the
level that you know
kind of what's the service
you want to deliver.
And then you're dealing
with tactical decision--
how you can optimize the cost
of delivering this service
and improve efficiency.
So did the third row
here basically deals
with the departure
times that are
given for all the
routes in the network
and for all times of day.
And then what you
need to do is how
you want to allocate
your resources in terms
of allocate the
vehicles to the system
to make sure that
that service is
going to be delivered on time.
So that would be the task
of vehicle scheduling input
into that task or
constraints that are involved
or running times on different
segments of the route
and also the departure times
that are given from upper level
decision-making process.
And it will eventually
result into a schedule
of given buses in terms of
what are specific trips they
need to serve and what's
the sequence of these trips.
Then the output from that
decision with the vehicle
schedules into the task
of scheduling for drivers,
this task also include
input from operator
and basically work
union constraints,
like maximum shift hours
and, for example, like,
break times and lunchtimes
and maximum separation
between two shifts.
And there are rules
and regulations
that are related to that.
And this task, again, is a
task of allocating resources
to minimize the cost
of scheduling drivers
to deliver the service.
And the result would be
the schedules for the crew.
So then these decisions can
be looked at in another way,
too, like, we can further
classify these decisions
into service planning decisions
and operational planning
decision.
Service planning decisions
would be the decisions
that define service as it
is perceived and understood
by public.
This is basically
the part of service
that is visible to the public.
And then there
are decisions that
are related to operations,
which basically
defines how operations occur
to produce the service.
This is somehow a black
box to the passengers.
And yeah, basically,
the passengers
should not really care
what's the vehicle's schedule
and what's the crew's schedule
that is assigned to the trip,
as long as trip is being
delivered as it is scheduled.
So in terms of other
characteristics
of these decisions,
we, basically,
for network design frequency
setting time table development,
vehicle scheduling,
and crew scheduling,
the decisions that are involved
in planning, basically,
starting from top to bottom
frequency of decisions,
basically are increased.
And the scope of
decision-making into the future
is basically become
limited and smaller.
And also, the decision-making
in the network design frequency
setting and timetabling
is basically
made based on guidelines
and standards.
And decision-making on the
lower level-- vehicle scheduling
and crew scheduling--
is made usually
based on optimization of cost.
And then given the nature of the
decision-making, the tools that
are used and the
techniques that are
used for solving these planning
decision-making processes
are basically ranging from
judgments and manual analysis
that is more dominated
into computer tools that
are basically designed to
solve optimization problems
for minimizing the cost.
So similar to the classical
evaluation structure,
when you're dealing with
planning questions and planning
projects or planning
alternatives,
there's this structure that
starts with goals, objectives,
measures, and standards
or guidelines.
So let's just make a quick
practice and define a goal
and then define
objectives for that goal,
and define measures
based on that,
and see how a standard can be
defined to make that planning
decision acceptable.
So let's define a goal.
Does anyone have any suggestion?
What is an important goal for
public transportation system?
AUDIENCE: Maximize ridership.
NEEMA NASSIR: Maximize
ridership, yes.
So let's say you want
to maximize ridership.
That's your research
problem, right?
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
NEEMA NASSIR: [CHUCKLING]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
[LAUGHTER] So then in
terms of objectives,
what would be an objective
that we can define for this?
I would say probably
the peak hour demand
could be one
objective or peak hour
ridership in certain corridor.
Let's say peak hour ridership
per weekday per month.
Well, peak hour ridership
would be the objective here.
And then the measure
that you would define
would be peak hour ridership
per weekday per month.
And then the standard
that you want to define
would be something
that not only captures
the demand side, but also the
supply of the system, too.
So you would come up
with probably, like--
I would, like--
AUDIENCE: Riders per vehicle--
riders per mile-- per hour.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah, exactly.
Or let's say, like,
60% of capacity.
Like, your standard
in this case would
be your peak hour ridership
should be greater than 60%
of capacity.
So this was just
an example that we
tried to work out one practice
for evaluation structure.
But let me give you another
example that is actually
used in the practice.
So assume that we
are considering
the goal of reliability
in the transit system.
The goal of reliability
would be considered
one of the main
goals because if we
have a reliable public
transport system, you can secure
and you can guarantee
a body of demand
in your network that can
rely on your transit system
and basically adapt to
the lifestyle of using
public transport.
And that's beneficial
to the system
from different perspectives.
So the objective
that we can define
for reliability in this
case would be possibly--
can you come up
with some objective
that we can define with the
goal of improving reliability?
AUDIENCE: On-time performance.
NEEMA NASSIR: On-time
performance, yes.
So on-time performance
would be the objective.
And then we need to
define a measure for this
to be able to measure
that objective
for each one of the
scenarios and for each one
of the alternative plans.
So what would be a measure
for on-time performance?
AUDIENCE: Characterizing with
our car driving [INAUDIBLE]
within a certain amount of time.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right, yeah.
So let's say percentage
of on-time arrivals.
So we would say percentage
of on-time arrivals,
and we would define
on-time arrivals
to be between 0 and 5
minutes of the schedule.
And then the standard
that many of the agencies
use to measure this would
be 90% or 95%, basically.
So this way, the
transit agency can
go ahead and evaluate the
performance of the operators
of the system who
basically are running
some part of the service
and come back to them
and say, OK, your performance
in terms of reliability
has been acceptable or not.
Please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
something [INAUDIBLE]..
Or would it be just standard
operating procdedure
they were planning as well.
And their reliability
was somewhere around 80%,
and now the goal is
to achieve a 10% gain.
NEEMA NASSIR: Mm-hm.
AUDIENCE: And comparing that
with the previous one would
be a benchmark again.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah, exactly.
So another measure would be
percentage improvements as
compared to baseline.
And then the transit agency
can define a standard
of at least 10%
improvement to the baseline
should be required
for reliability.
Yep, thank you.
So then one other
interesting point
that actually comes to mind
looking at the existing
guidelines is that on-time
arrivals are usually
defined for 0 to 5.
That basically means
that you consider
a bus that is late by two
minutes to be on time.
But a bus that is
early by one minute
is not considered to be on time.
Does anyone have any
comments about this--
why we do not consider
early arrivals on time?
AUDIENCE: I think
misconnections for people
who expected to be there
at a certain time, but--
NEEMA NASSIR: Right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: --they left.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] connected.
NEEMA NASSIR: So
it can be proved
that based on typical
assumptions about passenger
arrivals, early arrivals
of buses and service
is usually more negative
as later arrivals.
Let's make an example here.
For example, let's assume
under uniform arrivals
of passengers--
let's assume if
this is my scheduled
arrivals over the
axis of time and this
is my number of passengers
waiting in the bus stop
under uniform
arrivals, [INAUDIBLE]
you have some
accumulation of passengers
that are waiting at the stop.
And then what happens is that if
one of these buses are early--
let's say it basically
arrives at this time--
what happens is that
the amount of time
that we are saving
due to this arrival
is basically less than
the amount of time that
will be added to our waiting
time for the next trip.
And that's because the number
of people who are experiencing
this is a little higher--
number of people
that experience it,
saying, the additional
waiting time
is higher than number
of people who are
experiencing the early arrival.
And it cuts to
their waiting time.
So if you compare these two
areas, that basically tells you
you're basically
having a loss or having
an increase in waiting time
if your service is early.
And then the situation
becomes worse--
indicates that you suggested--
when people are coordinating
with the system--
for example, it
is assumed that--
and it can actually be proven
by looking at the data, too--
people make the transition
to coordinated behavior
and coordination with the
schedule as the frequency
of service increases.
For example, for a
service that is scheduled
to be delivered every half
hour or every one hour,
it is expected
that passengers are
coordinating with the
system and coordinating
their arrivals with the
departure of the buses.
But when it comes to
more frequent service,
then we will have
more uniform arrivals.
So in that case,
what we would observe
is that passengers arrivals
would resemble something
like this.
Well, it has to go up to
here, the original case.
And then in that case if
your service early by five
or 10 minutes, you will have
the main bulk of your passengers
who need to wait another
headway, basically.
So this should be actually
added to your computation, too.
Is there any
questions about this?
So in terms of the advantage of
guidelines in transit planning,
one of the main purposes
of these guidelines
is to communicate to
the public the rationale
and the logic behind
your decision-making
and behind your allocation
of resources to the system.
It also gives you a
consistent and fair basis
for decision-making.
And it is somehow gives you a
tool to justify your decisions
and also a tool to make
sure that your decisions are
fair and justified in nature.
It also gives you
the opportunity
to balance the improvement and
the investments to the network
and gain a uniform level
of service improvement
for efficient service.
So the guidelines that are
existing in the literature
and in the practice, basically--
in the state of practice--
are dealing with the
design of service
and with the
delivery of service.
So the design of service
basically dealing
with variables that
are related to spacing
and density of stops,
spacing and density of trips,
and frequency of the service
as it is designed and as it
is in the schedule.
So there are guidelines
related to that.
And there is also guidelines
related to how you deliver
or how the transit agency
delivers the design service
and how the performance
actually took place.
So the main factors of service
design and service quality
from the passenger's
perspective are basically
reported by transit
capacity and quality
of service manual of the
Transportation Research Board.
And it basically includes
frequency of the service as one
of the main aspects or
factors that are defining
the quality of service--
waiting time,
reliability, and access.
This is access over time
and also access over space.
So why do we again have
both frequency and waiting
time in here?
So if frequency and waiting
time are kind of interrelated,
how come there are two separate
items here on the list here?
Does anyone have any
suggestions about this?
So let me go ahead and
explain how I understand this.
Frequency of the service
is important not only
in terms of the waiting time--
that could be
associated with that--
but also when it comes to lower
frequency system and longer
headways.
The waiting time is not a
function of frequency anymore.
It basically, as we
discussed, the waiting time
could actually be
independent of frequency.
However, in those cases, there
is a burden of coordination
that is imposed
to the passenger.
So if you have to coordinate
your arrival, for example,
in the morning
from home to work,
then there is some
sort of inconvenience
that is imposed to you
to basically make it
to your coordinated schedule.
And then waiting time
is also important
because if the
service is frequent
but at different
ranges of frequency,
you may experience
different waiting time
if the process of
arrivals of passenger
is assumed to be
a random process.
Then reliability
as we discussed is
one of the important
features and one
of the important
aspects of the service.
It usually is a measure
based on on-time arrivals
of the service.
And then the next
aspect that is important
is access to origins
and destinations.
This access can be
interpreted in two ways.
We can look at access in terms
of space and in terms of time.
Access in terms of space is
closeness to the bus stops
and closeness to the
service from origin
and from the destination.
Access in terms of time would
be the span of service--
when you like to travel--
and basically, what
is the service time
and available times of service.
So yeah, as I
mentioned, most agencies
have guidelines covering
a span of service.
For example, MBTA
has this guideline
that for weekdays, you need to
have service from all suburbs
into the CBD area with--
at least, like, at latest,
arrives at 7:00 AM.
So you need to basically be
able to cover between 7:00
AM and 6:00 PM as your
services span in MBTA.
For TransLink, it's
also somehow the same.
You need to-- basically,
minimum service guidelines
to ensure that 95%
of trips listed
can be completed in the
time span given below.
Like, from any point
to downtown Vancouver,
you need to have service
that can actually
arrive in downtown
Vancouver by 7:00
AM, for people who should
start their work at 7:00 AM.
And then there's also
trips in the evening.
And it basically says earliest
departure time of mass transit
trip in the evening
from downtown Vancouver
to any town center needs
to be midnight for people
who basically
would like to enjoy
the nightlife in
the downtown area
and then use transit
to go back home.
So in terms of route
design and in terms
of layout of routes
and stops, there
are also guidelines that are
addressing this decision.
MBTA has a policy objective
to provide transit service
within walking distance,
which is defined a quarter
mile of all residents that are
living in area with population
densities greater than 5,000
people per square mile.
That's basically an
interesting guideline.
It considers two
different variables.
One is the population density.
And the other one is the
density of the stops or vicinity
or walkability of
transit in areas
that are populated with
densities greater than 5,000
per square mile.
So in terms of
comprehensiveness objective,
TransLink basically has very
comprehensive guidelines
related to basically a set of
different performance measures
and goals.
Let me read from these.
At least 90% of our
residents and employees
in urbanized
development areas should
have a walk less than
450 meters to a bus stop.
So this is related
to access over space.
98%--
AUDIENCE: When they say 90%
of residents and employees,
basically they're looking
at that person twice.
The person is on
one end, a resident,
and on the other
end, an employee.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right, yes.
AUDIENCE: So it's-- OK.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah, you want to
consider both ends of the trip,
right?
And these percentages
are a little tricky.
Sometimes they're counting
the number of people-- number
of residents.
Sometimes they're
counting OD pairs.
counting passengers.
So it's a little tricky to
interpret these correctly.
So the second one basically says
98% of all peak period transit
trips to and from
downtown Vancouver
should require no more
than one transfer.
That basically is 98% of
people who are traveling from
and to downtown to the suburbs.
And so it may be a little
difficult, especially
in the absence of AFC data--
Automated Fare
Collection system data.
It can be a little tricky
to measure these objectives.
What's usually
done, basically, is
people go out and basically
ask from transit riders
about their origins
and destinations.
It's called Public Transit
Origin Destination Survey
that is usually done on board.
Do you have a question?
OK.
So the second
measure here relates
to connectivity in the network.
The third one is 95%
of all peak period
transit trips to the
nearest town centers
should require no more
than one transfer.
Again, this one is also related
to connectivity of the network.
And fourth one is all trips
between one town center
and adjacent town centers
should require no transfers.
Again, this one is a
guideline on connectivity.
And then again, the last
one is also on connectivity.
It basically requires that
95% of all peak period transit
trips to major regional
activity centers and gateways
should require no more
than two transfers.
OK, so any questions
or comments about this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In terms of one
connectivity between one town
center and adjacent town
center, definition of a town
varies from place to place.
NEEMA NASSIR: Mm-hm.
AUDIENCE: I know that
specifically Vancouver
has rather large suburbs--
like, suburbs of
100,000 people--
200,000 people.
So you actually have a
few municipal entities
for a large area.
NEEMA NASSIR: Mm-hm.
AUDIENCE: But you can have
areas where that condition would
be a little bit too strict
if you have, let's say,
the Boston area,
which is generally
slightly smaller suburbs
and more suburbs to connect.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right, yeah.
So some of these may
actually be a little tricky
to measure and to quantify.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And they're able to compare.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, when I
see these numbers, then I
try to think about equity, and,
like, the 10% that is not 450--
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
AUDIENCE: --is it from that or--
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --a bus station--
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
AUDIENCE: --[INAUDIBLE] the 5% .
NEEMA NASSIR: Mm-hm.
AUDIENCE: So how do you navigate
these types of trade-offs
in the face of equity.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
This is a really good point.
Some of these
percentages, I think,
are related to random variables.
And those are somehow
acceptable because that's
when you try to define
a confidence interval.
But when it comes
to cases like this,
it is not a random
variable anymore.
It's basically like a special
variable that constantly
requires a certain amount of
connections to the downtown
area, right?
So that may be one of the
loopholes of this guideline.
That's a really good
point because one
may argue that if
95% of my OD pairs
are connected with the minimum
connectivity requirement,
what about the rest of 5%?
Does it mean that all people
who live in that 5% area
will have to go through the
unacceptable connectivity
situation?
So that's a valid point.
And thank you for
bringing that up.
AUDIENCE: Does Vancouver
actually achieve these goals?
It seems kind of implausible--
kind of difficult to--
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah, well,
these are basically usually
for projects and plans
that are being proposed
for-- or like small
start projects
or for improvement plans.
So I think what they try
to do is to make sure
that the ones that are being
accepted and being implemented
would satisfy this.
But I'm not really sure if
the existing network satisfy
all these conditions or not.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, is
TransLink the name
of the agency that runs the--
NEEMA NASSIR: Yes, right.
Yeah, right.
OK, so any other questions?
All right.
So then TransLink
guideline on route design
is very interesting, too.
They have really
interesting logic
to validate the design
and the improvements that
are proposed for route design.
So what it says is that
deviations from the most direct
route must have walking
time savings for customers
on the added route
section greater
than the increase
in total travel time
for through passengers.
So does anyone have
any interpretation--
quick interpretation--
on this guideline?
AUDIENCE: The only reason is
[INAUDIBLE] a major destination
where people [INAUDIBLE]
or otherwise people
are going straight and what
[INAUDIBLE] people on buses.
So the second to the
last stop on the route,
may be you make that
deviation to have
people on the bus [INAUDIBLE]
traffic [INAUDIBLE]
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
Yeah.
Right.
You have a comment, too?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEEMA NASSIR: Right, yeah.
So if you look at the problem
or look at the situation
from the perspective of system
and from the perspective
of total travel time in the
system, what they basically
are requiring is
that, for example,
let's assume that I
have a suburb here.
And then this is
my downtown area.
And there is a route here
that has multiple stops.
And then there's
another suburb here,
which, in the original plan
is being served by this route.
However, it requires a walking
link to different stops.
What this guideline basically
requires is that if the total
travel time for all passengers
for traveling from here to here
and for all that are traveling
from here to here is going
to be increased, then you cannot
justify an additional detour
here to serve this area, meaning
that if the total travel time
saving that is done on the
walking time of these people is
not as much as total increase in
travel time of people that are
traveling from this
suburb to this suburb,
then you cannot justify
the design or the re-route.
So in terms of
guidelines related
to a schedule and guidelines
related to frequency
and timetable, we
basically, in practice there
are two main
components-- component
that is related to the policy
of design and components
that is related to the
crowding situation.
Policy of design basically
dictate a minimum headway
or basically a minimal
frequency or maximum
headway for the service.
And that's basically
the case when
there is no crowding situation.
However, in the main corridors
and in peak directions,
we usually would go beyond
the service of policy headway
because we need to
accommodate the demand.
And that's basically how the
maximum passenger crowding
guides come into play.
So in terms of the actual
guideline on policy of headway
for MBTA, we have
maximum headway
on all local bus routes
should be 30 minutes in peak
and 60 minutes at other times.
For express routes, there
should be at least three trips
in each peak period.
So let's discuss a little
bit more about this.
Why do you think that we need
to have a policy headway--
maximum policy headway?
If we are considering
the demand and we
are trying to satisfy the
demand by number of vehicles
that we are assigning
to the route,
then why should we
care about a minimum?
Do you--
AUDIENCE: Because if the
demand is really low,
that person-- you can't
make him wait forever.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You'll have
to serve him equitably.
NEEMA NASSIR: Exactly, yeah.
Again, the equity issue and the
accessibility issue, basically.
AUDIENCE: And there
are also, you know,
still elderly people who
don't use smartphones
to coordinate their
arrival at the bus
stop when the bus is coming.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And you don't want
to make them wait indefinitely.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right, exactly.
Right.
OK, and then when it comes
to considerations related
to the crowding,
we have guidelines
about maximum crowding
and maximum expectation
of crowding that would
dictate a minimum frequency
for the service.
For example, for Green line,
the maximum passengers per car
should be no more than 225% of
the seats in the peak period.
In the off peak, the
maximum passengers
should be no more than
the seated capacity,
except in the central subway,
which can go up to 140%.
Yeah, so here is the
TransLink guideline
on frequency objective.
It basically defines different
headways based on time of days
and based on modes of transit
that the transit agencies
and operators of the
system need to satisfy.
So in terms of guaranteeing
that the load and the crowding
situation is addressed
in the guideline that
is related to frequency,
there is some analysis
that is done to make sure that
your frequency is high enough
that your crowding
situation does not
exceed a certain level.
Why do we care about the loads
and the crowding situation?
The first reason is
that we do not want
to frequently deny to board.
That would yield to
increased travel time.
And we would like to basically
avoid higher dwell time that is
associated with higher
number of boardings--
alighting number of
wheelchairs on board--
that would eventually, again,
increase the running time.
For example, in the acceptable--
in a regular
standard 40-foot bus
the acceptable load of 70
passengers are considered.
However, the average that we
estimate based on our design
should not exceed 55 passengers.
So that's the case
of indeterminacy
and the confidence intervals
that we kind of allow
in the analysis.
However, it's a little
different with the equity issue
that you mentioned in this case
because you want to make sure
that to a certain
degree of confidence
your system is performing at
an acceptable crowding level.
The variability to
demand could actually
relate to bulk arrivals
or group arrivals
that may happen at
once due to exchanges
from different service.
Or it could actually relate to
the variability in the headway
or variability in the nature
of demand based on day of week,
based on seasonality, based
on the weather condition,
and so on and so forth.
Then the other objective in
the guideline of TransLink
is the objective of comfort.
And it basically deals,
again, with the crowding level
or the design crowding
level or crowding averages
that we are basically
computing as objectives to be
tested for this guideline.
As you can see again,
for different peak
periods and different type of
vehicles and type of service,
there is published numbers
in terms of the averages
or computed averages for
the maximum crowding levels.
So look at these numbers.
Does anyone have any idea
of why some of these numbers
are larger?
For example, for peak 15
minutes in AM and PM peak,
you would allow an average
of 60 passengers on-board.
However, when it comes
to computations of peak
30 minutes, you
would only allow 55.
AUDIENCE: You don't want people
to be left behind because
of frequency of the services.
Knowing that there maybe
another hour or service
is another five minutes.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right,
yeah, that could
be one reason that actually
yielded to this design.
Any other thoughts
or suggestions?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the 15
minute peaking limit
allows you to have one
very full vehicle that
sort of would skew the
averages [INAUDIBLE]
and could moderate that.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: Is this like--
could be, like, a
chicken or egg problem
where the ones the routes were
needed with peak 15 minute
headway are ones that you
will expect a lot of people.
Or is it the other way around
where you see a lot of people,
and then you make
it [INAUDIBLE]..
NEEMA NASSIR: Yes, right.
Well, yeah, that's exactly
one of the considerations
in design of a frequency
and design of a schedule.
So if I want to reward--
what Ari mentioned-- if you're
computing your average over 15
minutes and then you're
computing your average over 13
minutes and you're observing
a higher crowding level over
the accepted level, then if
the situation becomes more
critical--
if you're computing
over 30 minutes,
it's more critical
than if you're
computing over 15 minutes.
So if you observe an
average of high crowding
level for 30 minutes
or for a longer period,
that is a sign of a
higher actual average
of crowding level.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's funny.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah, maybe
you explained it better.
I shouldn't have rewarded you.
So the other objective
that TransLink covers
is basically the
comfort situation.
This is one of the
interesting ones.
And I do not really
know how it's
possible to measure
this for a design.
It's probably usually being used
in evaluation of the existing
service.
It basically deals
with number of minutes
that you expect from
passengers to be standing--
maximum number of minutes
of being standing on board.
And there's a
level of compliance
that is defined for each one.
For example, you would
allow no more than 95% cases
that passengers would have
to stand more than 20 minutes
on the trip.
So I can imagine if you
have an existing system
and if you want to
measure this, you
can go out and
survey these numbers
and compute averages and
compute the distributions.
However, if you have a
design which is not in place,
does anyone have
any thoughts how
you can come up with some sort
of estimation for this case?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah,
simulation could be
one possible way of doing this.
Simulation of demand could be
AUDIENCE: You could check,
like, if it's a train--
I saw the Sky Train there, you
can see where the train fills
up and then assume
that everyone else--
everyone that boards
the train afterwards--
if you know how many people
are boarding-- if you have--
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
AUDIENCE: --data to
do that, then you
can assume that everyone who's
boarding after is standing.
And then you can see how many
of them have 20 minutes or more
left on the journey till
the train [INAUDIBLE]
NEEMA NASSIR: Exactly.
That's a good idea.
So what you're suggesting is
to generate the load profile
for the line.
And whenever the load is
over the seating capacity,
you measure the
time period on that.
So that's a good idea.
Right.
So in terms of for Toronto
Transit Commission,
the loading standards
is something like this.
For different types
of vehicle, you
would allow different
averages for your design.
So there is also one
interesting point here.
Why do you think for
low frequency service
you would allow a lower crowding
level or a lower average
ridership?
AUDIENCE: If it
was that crowded,
you would want to add frequency
to better serve people riding.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right, yeah.
That could be one good answer.
The other reason
that I can imagine
is that if it's a
low frequency service
and if someone is denied
boarding to a low frequency
service, they have
to wait longer.
So we would allow a little bit
of a slackness in the design,
so we would avoid a
situation like that.
OK, so let's stop here.
And then we will
continue through the rest
of the guidelines, particularly
with reliability of service
next week.
AUDIENCE: So there's
a question there?
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
AUDIENCE: I was going to
ask is there a reason why we
use so many Canadian transits?
NEEMA NASSIR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is there
a reason why we
use so many Canadian transits?
NEEMA NASSIR: That's
a good question.
AUDIENCE: Their public
transportation is better.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah, better--
probably the closest place
that has better
public transportation.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]